the defense to load up on you it makes  it tougher for you within that 24  seconds to get your offensive going  or getting a flow  i would venture to say that the bulls  over the last three weeks or so have  been much better at wearing teams down  on the defensive end  miles bridges i'm sorry i'm sorry  miles bridges how do you do how do you  do home diddley d  with the dunk miles bridges bridges  you can't let him come in there and get  those kind of dunks like that those are  deflating plays  he might i i think he overtook edwards  nice play by rozier but he missed it  like when he went i thought he was too  far out i mean vuch is right there  oh man man that's just another on the  highlight reel of miles bridges this  year  that's about where he took off from  against capela  maybe even a little bit further out i  think utah watanabe had  the uh dunk of the year by anthony  edwards i think capela got yammed on by  bridges that's the dunk of the year